I share a lot in common with these two
goats we both have big grunts in our
face we both like to have fun and we
both age
ing is a paradox when one considers
evolutionary biology
evolution is driven by natural selection
where advantageous traits are favored
over time and passed On to the Next
Generation
so how does aging fit into this equation
aging is a natural phenomenon observed
in many organisms and can essentially be
defined as an increase in mortality with
age
as we grow older our bodies undergo
various changes but what is the purpose
of Aging is it simply a side effect of
our biological processes or does it
serve a greater purpose in this video
we'll discuss this and deeply consider a
more recent proposal that aging evolved
as a pathogen control strategy
so there'll be three parts firstly we'll
discuss these different theories of
aging and why they have certain issues
with them then we'll introduce this
newer Theory
and lastly consider evidence for this
pathogen control strategy and why we
should even care about this
now aging is deemed bad as it increases
our likelihood of death and this is
reflected in many historical theories of
Aging
one theory that is still very popular is
this one called antagonistic play trophy
a concept proposed by the renowned
evolutionary biologist George Williams
according to Williams this Theory
suggests that certain genetic traits
that have beneficial effects early in
life may also have detrimental effects
later in life
in other words these traits can confer
advantages for reproduction and survival
during youth but can contribute to the
aging process or increase susceptibility
to diseases later on
William argued that natural selection
favors these traits because they enhance
reproductive success during the prime
reproductive years even if they come
with negative consequences and later
life stages
in a similar vein a second theory is the
Disposable SEMA theory proposed by the
biologist Thomas Kirkwoods and Kirkwood
suggests that organisms have limited
resources to allocate either maintenance
and repair processes or to reproduction
so according to his theory natural
selection would favor Australia where
resources are primarily directed towards
reproduction during early life stages
while the maintenance and repair of the
body are allocated secondary importance
as a result the same word that the body
undergoes wear and tear over time
leading to aging an eventual decline so
this Theory suggests the organisms have
a use it or lose its approach to
resources prioritizing immediate
reproductive success over long-term
somatic maintenance
so again highlighting that there may be
these evolutionary trade-offs between
reproduction and the long-term survival
and maintenance of the body now you may
be listening and thinking yeah this
makes sense but they both have their
limitations at least when you consider
some of the current observations that we
can see in nature
firstly they both suggest some sort of
pay later
in terms of there being a consequence of
diverting or using resources for
reproduction but what does this really
mean is it in terms of energy intake or
a lack of resources
if so why do some organisms appear not
to age at all and why does calorie
restriction the reduction in resources
seem to be one of the only strategies
that actually slow the aging process
plus there are even examples in natural
cases of rejuvenation for example in
some usocial organisms
so clearly these theories didn't fully
explain what's observed regarding Aging
in nature
so let's actually just flip this whole
thing on his head and ask instead could
aging be adaptive
now there are some sort of arguments
about living longer and being able to
pass on valuable bits of information
but two other theories suggest that
aging is adaptive because it accelerates
Evolution and another hypothesis is that
it's for population control
however both these theories could be
dismissed by considering that there are
other methods besides aging to control
for population size or to accelerate
evolution
so this brings us back to the pathogen
control strategy
and in essence this theory proposes that
aging evolved to prevent the spread of
infectious agents to younger kin
so let's explain a bit more so one
concept you need to grasp is Hamilton's
role Hamilton's role can be used to
explain altruistic Behavior so here
aging having a fitness course to the
person who's aging but the idea is that
the benefit is that this is preventing
the spread of the Seas to Kin
and so this is the formula if the cost
of the individual is less than the
benefit to the recipient multiplied by
the related nurse then in theory should
be selected or favored by natural
selection
so usually though aging is considered a
cost with no benefit to the kin
but according to this pathogen control
hypothesis aging might have evolved as a
way to prevent the spread of infectious
diseases among kin groups so older
individuals who carry chronic infections
May pose a threat to their younger
relatives who share some of their genes
so by dying sooner by aging these
individuals reduce the risk of infecting
their kin and increase their Inclusive
fitness
so it actually accounts for the sum of
all of their related Neighbors
so using this hypothesis then and
Hamilton's rule you can make some
predictions about what we might observe
in nature
for example where kin interactions are
more frequent and pathogens spread more
quickly you'd expose aging to be faster
in that species to prevent the spreads
conversely aging should be slower in
species that live in less viscous
populations where kin interactions are
perhaps less frequent and pathogens can
spread less easily
so this hypothesis also seems to suggest
that aging may be modulated by
environmental factors that affect
pathogen transmission such as
temperature humidity and social behavior
so where is the evidence
well firstly it can be modeled but more
importantly it can be observed take
flight for example
flights may also reduce pathogen
transmission by enabling animals to
avoid contact with infected individuals
or contaminated environments therefore
we would expect flying species to have
longer lifespans than non-flying species
of similar body size as predicted by
those pathogen control hypothesis and
indeed several studies have found that
flying species such as birds and bats
tend to live longer than non-flying
species such as rodents and marsupials
so why ultimately should we care about
this well why a process happens can give
Clues on how to intervene in this case
it suggests that the immune system is
looking at her compelling Choice along
with understanding how cells respond to
infection oh hey sin Essence and p53
but this is still an emerging strategy
that I have I have discussed in more
detail with Peter lipsky one of the
authors of this hypothesis I recently
interviewed Peter and so I released that
safely uh soon so that you can
understand this Theory a bit better and
understand more of the evidence
so to summarize perhaps aging is
adaptive and that resolves the Paradox
and it's also in alignment with a
previous video I made discussing their
aging as programs and it helps us to
better understand ways to intervene an
aging
so with that be on the lookout for this
interview hope you have learned
something here thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening